hello NDC Oslo
I'm Dylan I'm going to talk to you about
email
because like email is kind of important
right you ever get the thing where you
can't remember your password so you
click forgotten password they send you
an email you get locked out of your
account you click the button they send
you an email you want to go to sign into
Microsoft azira and they say oh no hang
on we just need to check it's really you
how do they check it's really you they
send you an email you sign up on a new
service so like we want to make sure
that you're not a Spam bot or some kind
of you know evil nefarious internet
criminal overload I'm going to send you
an email and you can use the email to
verify it so
email is a really really important
component in the fact that any of the
stuff that we do online ever actually
works at all
so we're going to do a little experiment
we're going to go here
now what I'd like all of you to do
you're going to go to that web address
and you are going to follow the
instructions
now there is a button that's going to
about to appear on your phone screen
that says don't press this button yet do
you know what that means
there is a saying that if they wrote on
a button do not press this button or it
will destroy the universe the paint
would not be dry before a human being
had slapped the button
do not press the button what I want you
to do is to follow the instructions on
the screen there we go let's bring up
our live update someone has matched the
button that little yellow at sign there
that's somebody who can't read the
documentation
and it's written in large friendly
letters how evil can it be
so we're going to just let that rack up
a little bit oh look at that
look at that are someone who's already
caused an error message well done
congratulations there we go look at that
someone's already gone all the way
through the process most of you it's
good to see every little white dot on
that that someone who is following the
instructions
no wait wait wait no no no no no no no
no stand up
the instructions say you stand up
so you stand up
stand up stand up stand up stand up
stand up everyone's standing up standing
up standing up
that looks like a statistically valid
sample right so what we're going to do
I'm going to count down from five I'm
going to get to zero you're allowed to
press the button
five
four
three
two
one
press the button
and we're going to send you an email
and when we do you are gonna go and
check your inbox and when you get the
email follow the instructions in the
email
all right I see a couple going green I
see a couple going pink some of the
stuff's getting through some of the
stuff is a gonna junk mail some of it is
still cute some of it's still sent
uh the little black ones there are
probably because I've pissed off every
email provider on the planet doing the
research for this talk and some of them
have decided that they are just not
going to talk to me anymore
so we're getting a fair few of those
going through
now
it's around about now that you've been
waiting long enough that if this email
was like your two-factor authentication
to get into Azure to fix a problem in
production or the password reset so you
can get into your Gmail to get your damn
plane ticket because you need to go to
the airport you'd be getting a little
bit why doesn't email work this should
have arrived by now well friends
I have some very distressing news for
you
everything is working absolutely fine
those of you who are still standing up
bear with me one more second this is the
SMTP specification latest version
October 2008 about how we should try to
deliver email and what it says is if it
doesn't work first time you should wait
at least 30 minutes
and then you should keep trying for four
or five days before you finally decide
that the email didn't work now anyone
who didn't get the email you are welcome
to come down the front at the end and
you can get one of these the sticker
that should have been an email that I've
I've got some of these printed out here
saying take all of those
these are the special NDC Oslo editions
of this so they won't look like this
ever again now I'm going to talk to you
about email and I'm going to talk to you
about why we have ended up with this
weird situation where the spec says that
an email can take five days but we built
the internet on the fact it takes about
15 seconds how did we get here now my
kind of credibility I guess my expertise
in the field of email it's something
I've been working with my entire career
in uh
when the internet had a connection
wizard one of my first like big
professional projects I ever worked on
was a project for this company Spotlight
is a a British directory of Show
Business job opportunities for actors
and actresses all those kinds of things
and uh I built an email-based job
information service so if you were
making a movie and you needed actors to
be in your movie you could go on
Spotlight and you could send out an
email now this was built in classic asp
and I had a for Loop and what it would
do is it would send an email and then it
would responds.write a DOT so you'd get
a screen that went dot dot dot dot dot
and then at the end we'd respond stop
flashing we'd redirect it's in about 200
emails a day it was Conquest up but the
system before that was built on fax
machines so this was a pretty neat idea
it was also a spectacularly successful
product it went from 200 emails a day to
500 to a thousand to two thousand to
five thousand by the time I left
Spotlight in 2018 this system was
sending a quarter of a million emails
out every day and that's not a quarter
of a million copies of the same
newsletter it's a quarter of a million
unique individual personalized emails
now that was an interesting phenomenon
that we noticed we catered mainly to the
English-speaking Show Business Market
in London about two o'clock every
afternoon show business would get back
from its nice boozy lunch in the pub sit
down and go I should probably send out
some emails what do you think Brian and
they go on Spotlight they'd bang in a
couple of things they'd send us out this
happened at the same time as New York
and Broadway had just finished their
latte and were getting ready to get set
into a solid day's work which was the
same time that Hollywood and Los Angeles
have finished their power breakfast and
started yelling at their assistance so
when I say a quarter of a million emails
a day it most of them went out in a
three-hour window every afternoon that
is a sustained rate of about 10 to 12
emails per second for three hours every
weekday for more than a decade
now you probably have a picture in your
head of what a professional actor looks
like
most of them don't look like the ones
you see on TV the ones you see on TV are
the ones who have made it because they
have a job right now the average
professional actor looks like this
because they're at home waiting for
their next audition and they are sitting
there and they are refreshing their
email now some of you might have had
complaints like companies uh you worked
at where you've sent email and people
have complained that you've sent them
anymore have you ever had someone to
phone you to complain that you hadn't
sent them email
because we used to get people ringing up
going I haven't had any emails for a
couple of hours is everything all right
and we'd be like well we think so maybe
there's just no work for you today but
we had to answer those calls and we had
to be able to explain what was going on
so my team and I got incredibly good at
understanding everything there was to
know about email delivery how does it
work why does it work why might it fail
now the whole time this is going on
because I'm an idiot I'm running an open
source mail server for me and all my
friends so Dylan beatty.net all the
email ran on an old Hewlett Packard
workstation that was locked in a server
cupboard somewhere for about 10 or 15
years now I eventually stopped doing
that and you'll find out why in the
course of the talk but then at the start
of this year who was NDC London I was
yeah
um some people who very nearly weren't
were people who work for a company I
won't name whose Corporate email
provider switched to a new spam
filtering service the week before the
conference and that spam filtering
service mimecast decided that send grid
was sending junk and so all of their NDC
conference tickets went to junk and we
had to kind of jump in and figure out
how did these people not get the tickets
they'd paid money for that were sent
directly to them and I thought that
might be an interesting talk in this
because lots of us build systems that
send email and lots of us kind of don't
really understand all the weird quirks
of how it works so
email is older than networks the first
computer that kind of really got her any
kind of traction was this thing the
compatible time sharing systems about
1961 and you could send mail on this
thing but send as a misnomer because
when you sent mail the mail didn't go
anywhere it was the equivalent of
leaving Post-it notes on a really
expensive refrigerator because this
computer was shared between 60 or 70
different researchers so when your
colleague came to work the next morning
and logged into that terminal you'd left
them a note that was the first use of
electronic mail this kind of went on for
a couple years and we're going to skip
forward
to 1969. now if the United States of
America was a Netflix show 1969 would be
a season finale big budget they pulled
out all the stops they did lots of
really interesting stuff 69 was the year
that people walked on the Moon it was
the year the Boeing 747 first flew was
the year the Lockheed SR-71 first flew
it was the year of Woodstock and the
summer of love all that kind of stuff
and it was the year that the upper net
was invented
now there were networks before the
arpanet the opponent was the advanced
research projects agency Network and it
looked like this this is a hand-drawn
sketch of the entire network now before
this there was a network but it was a
kind of ad hoc network of computers that
would dial each other up once or twice a
day and they'd swap messages and things
but when the arpanet came along for the
first time there was an idea of being
connected to the net this was the
network and if you were on it other
people could send messages to you now
modern email is a combination of
probably hundreds of people working on
solving smart problems over decades on
all kinds of platforms but one person
whose Innovation is still a significant
part of the way we work with it was this
guy it's Ray Tomlinson
and he was working on an opponent Mail
system in 1971 and Rey invented at
Rey is the person who went well hang on
if we know the user's name and we know
the arpanet host where they host their
email we could put an at in the middle
because it's Alice at the machine now
you notice that the hostname there is
just MIT multix it's not a DOT anything
it's not MIT multix.com it's just MIT
multix
because the network was so small that
computers just had a name and if you
bought a new computer you wanted to get
on the net you'd give it a name and then
you talk to Jake
this is Elizabeth fainler who everyone
called Jake for for some obscure reason
she ran the network information center
at uh Stanford from 1970 to 1988 and she
maintained the host's file the
definitive hosts file of the entire
internet and every year or two she and
her team would print it because you
could buy a print out of the hosts file
and this listed all of the machines
connected to the arpanet along with the
person responsible for maintaining them
telephone numbers street addresses and
email addresses
now there are two kinds of people in the
world there are the people who see
technology and go hey this is really
useful and there are the people who go
hey those people think this is useful
maybe I can use it to get rich
let's meet Gary Turk
now uh Gary took I punched his name into
Google to find a photo the guy's still
alive he's still working this is his
LinkedIn page like you could connect
with him after this talk if you really
wanted to
um but in 1978 Gary Turk was working for
the digital Equipment Corporation he was
a sales rep and his job was to sell
these the deck system 20. now this thing
had built-in arpanet protocol support it
was like you don't have to do anything
special you could plug it into a network
and it would just work and rightly or
wrongly Gary thought well I reckon
people who are on the upper net might be
interested in knowing about this
computer and digital didn't have a whole
lot of sales going on on the US West
Coast they had a big office on the East
Coast but West Coast you know California
Portland those kind of places they
didn't really have much of a presence so
he got his assistant
to go through the arpanet directory and
type in the email addresses of everybody
on the American West Coast who had an
email address
393 of them and put them now at this
point they overflowed the header field
so all the people who got this email got
an email which started with about 250
other people's email addresses
and then right down at the end of it it
says hey we invite you to come and see
the deck system 2020 and we'll be giving
presentations now has any of you ever
gotten trouble at work like maybe your
boss said please don't do that again or
maybe your boss shouted at you or maybe
the police shouted at you or maybe the
police shouted at your boss you ever
screw up so bad that the United States
military yells at your boss
because that's what happened
major Raymond chehor who was the uh the
U.S Air Force Major in charge of the
upper net because this was run by the
United States Air Force you know U.S
military project basically called Gary's
boss and said you do not do this ever
again we're very sorry now there's maybe
a little window right about then when we
could have fixed the problem but
everyone just went yeah don't send spam
or the American Air Force Will shout at
you we clear whatever I went yeah we
understand we'll be good from now on
we'll be nice we'll behave
we're gonna fast forward a little bit
now now you know that uh demographic
studies or populations kind of a group
people into Generations there are the
Baby Boomers and then there's there's
Generation X and then there are the
Millennials and then there's Generation
Z and then there's gen alpha or whatever
they're called in the new one and
there's this little Gap in the middle
the micro generation we're the people
who got email at the same time as
everyone else in the world got email for
the first time now if you are Generation
X it means you were born before Star
Wars
and if you are Millennial it means you
were born after Return of the Jedi and
the people in the middle are the
millennial Falcons
represent
how many of my fellow Falcons we got out
there today awesome
now the millennial it was kind of this
weird micro generation we're the ones
who like grew up in a world where we had
broadcast TV and our first job we had
email so we kind of had the analog
childhood and then our adulthood has
been completely digital but it turns out
that the internet is a millennial Falcon
because when Star Wars came out in 1977
there was the opera net it used NCP the
network communication protocol
everything was managed by the host's
file which you had to go and get a copy
of from Stanford University and junk
mail didn't exist no one had done that
yet when Return of the Jedi came out in
May 1983 the opponent had become the
internet these NCP was gone TCP was
everywhere we're all running on this DNS
had been invented we had a hierarchical
domain name addressing system and junk
email was very much a thing
now uh one of the things invented in the
early 80s there was SMTP it's created by
this guy John postel SMTP was published
in 1982 and has been incredibly
successful now the problem with
successful systems is you need to
maintain an obscene level of backwards
compatibility if you bring out an email
system at any point in the last 40 years
that doesn't talk to all the other
people who are already using email no
one's going to use it because it's
useless because you can't communicate it
is the equivalent of going out and
buying a 2022 MacBook M1 or M2 Pro and
finding that it has a cassette player
so that you can still load your
PowerPoint slides from 1982. this is how
backwards compatible SMTP systems and
relays have to be and one of the things
defined in that request for comments RFC
821 was the format of an email address
now uh quit your hands how have you
who's written code to validate email
addresses
keep your hands up if you use the
regular expression
yeah so I mean validating them in code
is kind of but we know an email address
when we see one right like uh wait we're
looking at our friends in The Avengers
we got Iron Man at avengers.com that
looks valid right
um and Spider-Man well yeah that's
probably going to work uh t'challa the
avengers.com that's gonna root obviously
nothing wrong with that
rocket plus Groot I'm not sure now
what about Bruce the Hulk Banner at
avengers.com
what about no vision doesn't give a
about DNS Vision it's going to use IPv6
hard-coded literals in square brackets
boom
how many of these would your email
validation routine have accepted
they are all valid
these addresses are all completely valid
email addresses according to the RFC
specification for internet email
addresses
so maybe validity is not really the
question we should be asking ourselves
we're going to pull some email addresses
apart and see how they actually work now
an email address has a domain part and
this controls where it's going and it
has a local part that controls what
happens when it gets there so what we're
going to do we're going to walk through
the process of actually speaking the raw
protocol that we use to send email
addresses so I'm going to use a tool
called nslookup here cool kids use dig
because dig is what runs on Linux and
everything but a dig doesn't come with
windows so this is nslookup which is
available on most platforms I'm going to
do an NS lookup name server lookup and
I'm going to say hey I want to know MX
set type equals MX mail exchanger
records I want to know which computers
on the internet are the mail exchanges
for this domain fun with DOT email and
it's going to say oh here you go look
smtp1 smtp2 there's a number in here
called an Amex preference now some
people call this priority that is a
stupid name for it because a loan number
is a higher priority
preference number 10 means try this one
first if you can't get through the 10 go
to preference number 20 the bigger
number means wait try that one later so
that's the computer we need to talk to
we're going to talk to smtp1 so I'm
going to telnet into that on Port 25 and
it's going to say hey nice to see you
and I'm going to say hello I'm Dylan
beatty.net and it's going to say 250 I'm
smtp.fun with email and I'm going to say
I have mail from Dylan dylanbeatty.net
and it is going to say 250 okay and I am
going to say recipient 2 hello at fun
now this is where it gets interesting
because that recipient 2 is the point
where we say to that system this is who
we want to talk to
now I wanted to find out what actually
works like never mind what the
instruction manual says I don't care
what's in the spec what actually works
out here so I went on Google and I
googled the best email providers for
doing stupid experiments
and then I went no no let's go with
something we're going to go with uh best
business email hosting and I troll
through a bunch of search results now
one that I just want to highlight
because it is the most wonderful piece
of hallucinatory Journalism I've ever
seen this article from PC Magazine in
2020 the best hosted email providers are
Salesforce
Microsoft Office 360 users should get
their email from GoDaddy web hosting
Zoho loyalists should use Zoho Mail and
the best email for Microsoft
organizations is teams
um in case you're not familiar with
business email hosting this is like you
go into cars magazine you say what are
the best economy family cars in 2020 and
it says well there's the Hyundai Tucson
there's bicycles there's a submarine and
there's penguins
I don't like
yeah right
um but I also found quite a lot of good
solid articles that were recommendations
for which companies people use in 2023
to host email and so I picked a bunch of
those now
disclaimer here
this is not a review of business email
Services I do not want anyone here going
away and choosing an email platform
because of something that I said in this
talk what I'm doing here is the
equivalent of testing cars by filling
them with gravel setting them on fire
driving them off a bridge and seeing if
they explode before they sink
it's interesting every provider I'm
going to show you is a rock solid
platform they all do email really really
well until some idiot like me comes
along and tries to poke them with a
stick
so I identified from looking at all
these articles the big players right now
Office 365 and Google are the ones that
really kind of dominate the space Zoho
have a lot of support from people who
don't want to use the big platforms
protonmail is very popular because they
have really strong commitment to
security and FastMail is uh so
disclaimer fast mounted company I've
used to host my mail for years and years
personally I love them I have no
problems with them
um but I'm just a regular pay-in
customer of all these Services there's
no I haven't talked to them there's no
endorsements so I set up email domains
for every single one of those set up all
the DNS records all the anti-spam
records everything and then I went
through to see how many email addresses
I could register so let's try to
challenge with the apostrophe in it
Google yep no problem
Office 365 yeah no problem
go on to uh Zoho Mail it let me register
it but then when I click on it
apparently they didn't tell the people
who built their front end that there
might be apostrophes in the Json and the
email addresses so uh we're going to
give that one a frowny face protonmail
just says no you can't have that not
allowed and I go on a fast mail and I
said please check this so no can't do
that not allowed let's try rocket plus
Groot now I go on a Gmail and I try and
create a mailbox and it says you can't
contain special characters so it looks
like you can't do that but Google has a
weird feature and it's quite a neat
feature if you have a bunch of email
addresses so we've got Iron Man at gmail
we got Iron Man plus Jarvis we got ion
dot man we got ion dotman plus Jarvis we
got I don't know
these all go to the same place
because Google decided they don't want
some situation where I'm Dylan Beatty
and you're Dylan dot BT and we're
different people they went that is too
complicated for humans to understand
and the plus thing the nice thing about
that is it's preserved so when you sign
up for like a mailing list you could be
like dylan.bt plus NDC gmail.com and
then if that shows up in a data breach I
know which company the breach came from
so this is plus tag tracking this is a
Google feature it's not part of an email
standard but it is worth knowing about
if you're working with mail
deliverability so actually rocket plus
grew on Gmail is kind of a smiley face
um Microsoft 365 says no you can't have
that so it's a cross for them Zoho Mail
says invalid username all right fair
enough protonmail nope you can't have
that and FastMail says this name's
already taken
which it isn't because I just registered
that domain it's not taken but yeah
we're going to give that one a a sad
face now Bruce Banner in quotes the
email spec says that you can have a
quoted local part containing spaces
there is not a single provider on the
planet that I found which will let you
create a mailbox
but then I thought all right well enough
fun with the sensible addresses what
about single apostrophe
Google yeah
Microsoft yeah Zoho Mail no protonmail
no FastMail no what about single hyphen
now this is where Google says email
cannot be a single hyphen I'm like what
about a double hyphen and Google goes oh
yeah you can have that one
that's fine
Office 365 minus at is fine that's
legitimate uh Zoho says no proton says
no that name is already taken again it's
not I don't know what the validation
thinks is going on here FastMail says no
so this is the set of aliases that I
managed to create there this is the
Google admin for gg.fun with DOT email
to Charles in single apostrophes in
minus minuses in underscore is in uh
last one I wanted to try was just
underscore at Google says yes Outlook
says yes Zoho says well Zoho says I put
it in I click add and it says ass 101.
and I'm like I wonder where that came
from so I open up the Chrome Network
inspector I take the request apart and
it says status code 200 s101 now where I
come from 200 means okay right so I
don't know why it's red but we're gonna
go with we're not quite sure what
happened there and finally underscore at
FM
FastMail just says great choice
so there we go
so next I thought all right never mind
creating mailboxes I'm going to create a
catch-all address I'm going to create a
dress that says anything at this domain
should go to that person over there
anything that's deliverable because I
wanted to see if I could push the limits
of what spec email addresses would
actually do that's where I hit a little
bit of a problem because I went on a
Gmail and I tried to send an email to
quote Bruce space Banner quote and Gmail
says no Gmail says you can't send mail
to that person it's not recognized and
that's just it doesn't exist
um protonmail their interface said the
same thing email address format is not
valid I'm thinking Hmm now what we can
conclude from this is an email address
valid
does it contain at least one at sign
because if it doesn't
no
but if it does then it depends
can an email address be case sensitive
the answer is yes if you're evil
when SMTP was introduced in the early
1980s the way that it got rolled out was
most people who already had a system
that had mail added an SMTP connector to
it and most of those systems ran on Unix
and Unix has a case-sensitive file
system and it means that your mailbox
has the same name as your mailbox file
which has the same name as your user
which means that Alice with a little a
and Alice with a big a could be
different people on the same Unix
machine
and so when you connect an SMTP relay
the spec says that once it gets to where
it's going if the local administrator of
that system has made it case sensitive
that should be delivered intact you
should never ever modify the case of
somebody else's email address now this
is where the airline industry turns up
and goes we have Cobalt mainframes your
email address will be uppercase whether
you like it or not so when Alex Goes to
Alice here goes to buy an email ticket
and get it sent to her unix.box.edu
account she's not going to get anything
because big Alice and medium Alice
they've got mailboxes but Capital Alice
doesn't exist so can email be case
sensitive it can if you really want it
to but it probably shouldn't be
so we're going to go back to here we're
going to do our 1980s flavored we got a
hello we got mail from we've got
recipient to so it's okay we're going to
say data and it's going to say go ahead
end your data with a new line dot new
line and we're just going to say Hello
dot boom 250 okay queued quit bye bye
and there it is we sent an email using
1982 flavored raw SMTP typing into a
Windows terminal the only challenge with
this is finding a network that will
allow you to do it and we'll find out
later why that's interesting now
this is where I start thinking well hang
on Gmail and proton won't let me send
emails with spaces in them but I've just
proved that we can hack into the Matrix
we can send code directly so I thought
what if I go to protonmail look up their
mail exchanger tell net into it hello
mail from hallowed fun with email
recipient to that it says Ah protocol
error okay that's not going to work
let's try it again Zoho what have they
got boom tell it into that one hello
mail from recipient to
now I'm not relaying because that's
their domain I'm giving them money to
host that but apparently they've decided
that that's relaying and they are not
going to let me relay sad face let's try
Google
telnet boom there we go we're in hello
mail from yep okay recipient two that's
not a valid RFC 5321 address also that's
a lie it is a valid RFC 5321 address
Google is lying to your face but they
Google you know what are you gonna do so
that doesn't work now I tried to do this
with the Microsoft account and uh I
could not find any Network anywhere that
Microsoft would let me inject mail from
because every single place I tried I
just got access denied band sending so
the NDC conference Wi-Fi didn't work
Hotel Wi-Fi didn't work tell that on my
phone didn't work onboard Wi-Fi on
Norwegian air didn't work Deutsche Bahn
Railway onboard Wi-Fi didn't work
Microsoft are really good at working out
who might be trying to send spam from a
moving train in Germany and making sure
that that doesn't happen
yeah Azure blocks Port 25. you can't
send mail from Azure or AWS or Google
Cloud we'll talk about that in a bit
yeah probably and everyone at NDC and
everyone in the hotel I'm sorry it's
research you know start with let's try
it with FastMail
so I got that mail exchanger tell it
hello mail from recipient two whoa
okay
data
there we go this was sent to an address
with spaces in it and it worked let's
see if it worked quit Okay bye
there it is
it worked delivered to an email address
containing spaces because this is what
the specification says email should do
now what we've just done there every one
of those Services we have done the
digital equivalent of like let's imagine
that we want to email we want to send a
letter a physical letter to this you
know who this is right this is Lazarus
he's the president of Malawi and he
lives here and so we want to send a
letter to him so we're going to write a
letter put it in envelope and we're
going to go to Malawi get on a plane fly
land a little long way we're going to go
out of town go up to the the
presidential Palace at the top of the
hill and we're going to go hello hello
we have a letter for his Excellency
now one that is not an efficient way to
deliver mail and two he might be out in
which case we have a deliverability
problem so
what can we do instead well we do this
we put a stamp on it and we put it in a
mailbox and we assume that we can find
any mailbox anywhere on the planet we
can put a letter into it and if we put
the correct postage on it'll go where it
needs to go now mailboxes work because
there is a physical and financial cost
to sending printed mail you've got to
buy a stamp you've got to buy printing
have you seen how much printer ink costs
like if you want to sell bad penis
enlargement procedures to a hundred
thousand people you're not going to do
it using a Hewlett Packard inkjet
printer the business model just doesn't
work so this kind of mail
it's kind of self-regulating up to a
point
but let's uh let's have a look at what
we've got in my inbox here now I've got
a message here from Lisa Williams she's
looking for a special friendship
web design prices on Google cross-border
Payments International an investment
opportunity for you your subscription
has been confirmed important message
FedEx International
[Applause]
I have a new voicemail message
let's give it up for the NDC Viking spam
choir
into it
you ever wondered why junk mail is
called spam
so spam is spiced ham it's this it's
meat in a tin which has been around for
years and Monty Python did a sketch in
the 70s where someone's in a cafe and
the things on the menu are egg and spam
and egg and bacon and spam and egg and
spam and spam and sausage and spam and
spam and spam and spam and spam and for
reasons I will never understand uh in
the cafe where the clip said there is a
chorus of Vikings
who sing the spam song and I put the
Monty Python clip in the video and then
I thought I'm going to be annoyed with a
bunch of loud hairy men we don't need a
video clip we can do this one live
and yeah so spam email as a reference to
that sketch where the noise of the spam
spam spam just drowns out everything
else that's going because that's what
happens with junk mail we have these
unsolicited emails and the reason we're
getting them is because email was
invented by hippies
and hippies suck at security
now things just kind of rattled on a
little while you know 1980s sort of came
and went and for a long time in the 80s
every mail server on the internet was on
open relay because peace and love man
and Good Vibes and yeah we'll help you
relay your mail to anywhere then the 90s
comes along
and what happens in the 90s is a lot of
people who've never had email or the
internet before they get the internet at
home and the thing you've got to realize
about what was happening in the 90s is
that stuff that was impossible is now
happening daily someone gets their first
email account and a couple of days in
they get an email from their
granddaughter in Australia with a photo
of the new baby and that was impossible
like a year previously you could not do
that it took three weeks to send
photographs from Australia to Europe
suddenly those things happen they're
like ah the internet's absolutely magic
it's brilliant it's amazing the next
thing in their inbox is Bill Gates
saying he's going to give them a million
dollars and everyone gets a free trip to
Disneyland and they're like well the
last thing was too good to be true but
then it happened maybe this one's too
good to be true but maybe this one will
happen as well we had no frame of
reference as a population for what email
couldn't could not do and what was
possible on the internet and so junk
mail scams spams bad medication became
an absolutely Rife problem most of it
sent through open email relays now there
were four approaches that we took to try
and stop this one of them
was they made it against the law
the controlling the assault of
non-solicited pornography and marketing
can spam Act of 2003 now as you can tell
this was a resounding success because
after 2003 there was no more junk mail
right yeah now it turns out that quite a
lot of people aren't in America
and quite a lot of people who are in
America don't give a crap and even the
ones who do it's very very hard to
prosecute them because it's ridiculously
easy to comply with the specifics of the
can spam act so law enforcement did not
deliver a solution
the second approach we tried was
client-side filtering you have some
software that sorts out your email now
most of us use that I use that you know
I have Gmail and it puts stuff in my
inbox and updates on social and that
kind of stuff I'm not going to talk
about that today because as a developer
trying to send you an email what you're
doing with it after I've delivered it
that is your problem and I don't care
how you've got it set up you can filter
anything you want there's very little
consistency that's on you to get set up
the way you want to do it there's maybe
some interesting stuff here about trying
to training machine learning systems but
like that email that I sent at the
beginning of this session that all of
you said yes I want to receive this
email quite a lot of it went to junk how
would you train an algorithm to know
that you're in Oslo right now doing a
live demo and this is important so when
I'm going to talk about client-side
filtering
what about verification one of the
problems with unsolicited email is that
you are not accountable there's no way
of tracing the junk mail back to the
person who sent it and if there was it
would be easier to find those people and
tell them to stop what we need
because we need peace and love and
Authentication
and the problem is they didn't include
that because the hippies didn't think we
were going to need it so when SMTP was
created it has no support no usernames
no passwords no security no encryption
absolutely nothing and so we looked at
the SMTP and we went oh simple mail now
we didn't want to make the complicated
mail transfer protocol that might have
put people off so instead we made the
extended simple mail transfer protocol
now this was actually invented at Jim
Henson's Creature Shop because uh the
difference between SMTP and asmtp is the
SMTP you say hello and esmtpc you hey
hello which is close enough
so we're going to do an extended smte
SMTP transcript we're going to tell that
into my fun with email server and we're
going to say hello Dylan beatty.net and
it's going to go oh cool you speak the
like cool kids language look this is the
stuff that I can do for you I support
authentication using the plane system or
the login system or the crime md5 system
I support start TLS which means we can
switch this whole thing to a secure
Channel and I do enhanced status codes
and we're like all right well before we
send our username password we probably
want to switch to the secure TLS thing
so we're going to start TLS by the way
lots of people still call this SSL
because SSL was invented at Netscape in
the 90s and everyone went yay secure
sockets makes the internet secure SSL
stopped being a good idea in 1999 but by
then we'd all got used to talking about
SSL certificates these days it's
actually TLS transport layer security so
we're going to send start TLS and it's
going to go yeah okay go ahead now we're
secure start again on a secure Channel
hello dylanbt.net there's our SMTP
handshake and now we can say this is our
username and password meshed together
base64 encoded so it's technically not
encrypted it's just encoded but that's
going to say authentication successful
and now we're in so we've said this is
us look we're a paying customer please
relay email for us
but the fourth approach
is let's stop the bad people being able
to get onto the internet in the first
place now
there's a guy called John Gilmore John
is a very interesting person he's one of
those people who I agree with everything
he does right up to the point where I
think he turns into a bit of a dick and
then he kind of stops just past that
point John was employee number five at
Sun Microsystems he was one of the
founders of the Electronic Frontier
Foundation he is a uh I've seen him
described as an extreme libertarian
cipherpunk activist and uh the most
famous quote I've seen from John is this
one the net interprets censorship as
damage and Roots around it if you start
blocking ports because you don't like
what people are doing the internet is
designed to find another way rounded and
you know he has taken this philosophy to
an extreme he runs an open mail relay if
you go to hop.toad.com it will accept
email from anyone on the planet on Port
25 and it will deliver it doesn't care
who you are doesn't care where you came
from which is kind of the libertarian
ethos in a nutshell like you shouldn't
have to show your ID to be able to take
advantage of Public Services which I
kind of agree with except where the
internet is concerned because it becomes
too easy to abuse it now I really wanted
to use toad.com in the demos I put
together and in the live demo we did at
the beginning
I couldn't because none of the networks
that I'm able to connect to would let me
relay mail through hop.to.com they just
said you can't do it I can't connect if
you put a system in Azure on an Azure VM
or you know an app service and say hey
connect to that system on Port 25 says
no you can't connect to anything on Port
25 don't send spam Google Cloud same
thing Amazon web services same thing
most uh you know dial up most connected
Wi-Fi most public Wi-Fi can't connect to
anything on Port 25. so we can't use
this open relay approach to send mail
the only way we've got a sending mail is
to find someone we have a relationship
with and use our username password to
connect to their server so that's fine
when we want to use our internet
provider or our email service to send
mail to the rest of the world
but what about receiving it
because the beautiful thing about email
is that anyone on the planet can send me
a message and I should be able to get it
and this is what sets it apart from
things like WhatsApp and Twitter and
telegram there is no multinational
corporation whose algorithm is showing
me things they think I want to see I
should be able to guarantee that anyone
can send me an email and I will receive
that email be able to look at it which
means it needs to be wide open if I'm
hosting my mail on Gmail I can't expect
everyone talking to me to set up a
Google account to be able to do that
likewise Microsoft so when a mail
arrives When someone knocks on the door
of fun with email and says hey I got an
email here for Dylan what can we do to
determine whether that's legitimate well
first
we can look at the envelope we can look
where did it come from where was this
mail sent what was the network address
it came from does that appear in any of
the public databases of known spamming
Network addresses now this system kind
of works up to a point it stops a lot of
spam I'm not going to pretend it doesn't
it's also a massive pain in the ass
because anyone who wants to give you a
bad day can just find your email address
and they can report it for spamming and
these places most of them don't verify
anything they're just like okay well
we'll add you to the list and if it's a
problem the system administrator can
come on and they can request to be taken
off the list again now one
people will do this just for for a lot
two people will block entire blocks of
IP addresses if your ISP has given the
next address along to someone who's
sending junk mail you could find you've
been blocked through no fault of your
own you can only deal this from these
things most of them say once every 48
hours there's about 10 or 12 of these
services this is why I stopped running
my own mail server it's because I got
fed up of going onto these forms and
saying no you've blocked the entire
network block again and I'm not sending
spam I'm doing everything right stop
cutting me off so this system doesn't
work it's too easy to abuse and it kind
of relies on your innocent until proven
guilty but proving you guilty just means
someone went it was them and then we're
gonna block you for the rest of your
life unless you beg and grovel and try
and get reinstated
let's talk about a better system
now there's a thing called SPF the
sender protect send a policy framework
and this is beautiful because it's built
on top of the things we had at right at
the start of the 80s it's built on SMTP
and it's built on DNS if you get a the
Google admin toolbox and you look up fun
with email on their dig toolbox you can
click through the records there's a
thing here called txt records and in
there you'll see this record here it
says txt time to live is short-lived and
value equals what value on this thing is
this V equals SPF one version is the
sender policy framework version one then
I got a rule here that says okay this
email that is allowed to send email for
that domain fun with DOT email
spf.smtp.com that's allowed SPF dot
messaging engine.com that is allowed and
anything else I got a little squiggly
thing says this might be suspicious so
what that qualifies them in a plus means
a pass this rule matches you can deliver
the email question mark means don't care
now that's not much use in production
but it's really good for testing stuff
because you can create your SP PF
records and see what matched without it
changing any Behavior a tildeer is a
soft fail flag it but deliver it and a
minus if I put a minus in there now the
plus is the default so normally you
don't see those the records actually
look like this but that minus there I
can put a rule that says look if anyone
anywhere on the internet gets an email
that says it comes from fun with DOT
email and it doesn't match that rule you
can just ditch it like that's fine with
me I'm telling you that's junk I
guarantee these are the only people
sending email on my behalf now there's a
couple of other systems we're not going
to go into today which do public key
cryptography there's a thing called a
decim domain key identified mail and
there's a thing called dmarc which is
the same but it then sends you reports
of anyone who's trying to pretend
they're you and spam stuff but this idea
of building records on top of DNS to
manage email this is getting some
traction this is working pretty well now
when we sent that a SMTP transcript
earlier we basically sent a message just
said hello like once we've thrown the
envelope away we don't know where it
came from we don't know who sent it we
don't know who they think they sent it
to we just know that it said hello we
want to send messages which are slightly
more useful than that and so when we
connect to our mail server and we get to
the point where it says Hey data send us
your message what we're going to do is
we're going to send a block of headers
this is who it's from this is who it's
to this is the subject this is the email
body it's going to say okay 250 cubed
we're going to say quit it's going to
say buy and that is going to work
brilliantly we get nice formatted email
and this works great as long as
everything that you have to say can be
expressed in seven bit ASCII because
SMTP is built on ASCII now seven bit
ASCII was a brilliant idea in the United
States of America in 1960s so was
Richard Nixon and leaded gasoline like
you know we can do a little better but
backwards compatibility you can't ship a
mail system which can't send mail to the
people who are still old system so here
in 2023 we are still stuck with seven
bit ASCII as the only way of sending
anything over an email platform
and so we have to use mime the
multi-purpose internet mail extensions
what mime is is a way of taking just
about any kind of content and turning it
into seven bit ASCII sending it over the
wire and rehydrating it at the other end
now mine was actually pretty clever it's
a very very elegant system so we got our
headers from to subject data's this now
mine version 1.0
mine's supposed to have other versions
it was supposed to have 1.1 1.5 2.0 3.0
but they never figured out how that was
going to work so basically we are stuck
with 1.0 being a floating Point Boolean
that if it's 1.0 yes and anything else
means this is probably not valid mine
now we're going to throw in a content
type here we say this is a multi-part
mixed message and the boundary string is
this now this can be anything you like
as long as it doesn't appear in your
message anywhere we're going to put in a
message now this this is a multi-part
message in mime format this is for old
old email readers that don't know about
mime there aren't very many of them
around anymore
now we get to the good stuff so that's
the header on our message
I'm going to put in a boundary it says
we're starting a block here and this
block is multi-part alternative that
says we're sending you the same message
but in two or three different ways so
we've now got a different boundary we're
going to say right this is the text
plane version of this email hello we're
having fun with email and then we are
going to have the HTML version hello
we're having fun with email this bit is
an HTML format and then we're going to
close out that boundary block and then
we're going to close out the other one
so now we've put another container so
mime is actually a tree structure you
can have containers inside containers
inside containers and in this one we're
going to say hey we're going to do an
attachment here this is fun with
email.png it's base64 encoded because
that's 7-bit ASCII safe that's the file
name it should be an attachment so this
should show up as a little paper clip in
your email client and then we're going
to have this massive great big long
block of base64 encoded stuff now
this is all well and good these are
standards you can go out you can study
them you can figure out how they work
you can write your own implementations
if you are actually building an
application that works with any of this
stuff you have a whole bunch of
challenges ahead of you not least
because email is an open standard and
when you create code to send somebody a
message you have absolutely no idea what
device they are going to be using to
look at that they might be reading it on
Yahoo they might be reading it on
Outlook or an Android phone they might
be using a screen reader there is a
whole raft of different things out there
and these days most email is HTML
because HTML looks nice and because our
marketing teams want us to send HTML
emails so we can have buttons and colors
and links and those things in it
HTML email is horrible it is one of
humankind's terrible terrible mistakes
good news is that there are Services out
there that mean you don't kind of have
to touch the icky bits quite as much as
you used to one of these is a thing
called the mailjet markup language
explain so mailjet is an email marketing
and relay company and mjml is their way
of writing HTML emails there's another
one which is called Foundation
foundation for email then I have a logo
but they do have a picture of a squid or
a cuttlefish so I thought all right
we'll put that in here now fundamentally
what these things do is they give you a
language which looks a bit like HTML
so I'm going to write an email and this
is mailjet markup language so I got a
male jet head with a preview I've got a
body with a section and a column now
this is it looks like HTML it's an XML
kind of compliant dialect it's not HTML
what we're going to do is we're going to
run this through the mailjet compiler
because the HTML that clients actually
understand
looks like this
it is a sack of Horrors
if you read this closely what we've got
there is we've got a table inside a
table inside a table and if you're on a
Microsoft Outlook or Internet Explorer
platform you get two extra tables for
free because the blue comments there are
the Microsoft if this is Microsoft
Outlook then include this extra chunk of
markup now I know people who used to
write this stuff by hand I used to write
this stuff by hand platforms like
mailjet have made the whole thing so
much easier to manage one of the things
that they don't really do is general
purpose templating they are transpilers
they have no idea of behavior they don't
work like a view engine like Razer or
something so what you can do we're not
going to go into the specifics in this
talk but you can have projects where you
take mailjet and when you compile it you
turn your mail jet into Razer and then
at runtime you put a model into your
razer and you get populated HTML with
individual order items and stuff at the
other end if you want to see how that
works I got some code up on GitHub you
can go and poke around with it so you
get to the end of it
and it works on your machine
which is kind of pointless because why
would you send yourself email you know
how do you test this stuff if you're
developing A system that is going to
send emails there's a couple of rules
that I absolutely live by so the first
one is you want an end point on your
website somewhere where you can see what
the email is supposed to look like
um the NDC tickets platform that we use
in London and Copenhagen and Porto
um every single order in that there's a
link at the bottom where you can say hey
show me what that email's supposed to
look like now one this is useful just
from being able to check details on
something also when you're designing
this stuff you can just keep refreshing
that page because it's way quicker to
reload the page or to use like a hot
reload or you know web plugin then I
have to send yourself an email wait for
it to come through go to your inbox open
it up ah still doesn't look quite right
round we go again so this gets you to
the point where it looks right next tool
that I use a thing called paper cut now
Papercut is a Windows application that
just sits in the corner of your screen
and your system notification tray and
it's an SMTP server that doesn't send
email every email that you send it
intercepts it and it goes yeah we got it
here it is and it lets you go through
and inspect all the properties so you
can see your message in a browser view
there that's pretty good you can see
your message headers what exactly got
filled in by the code that you were
using to generate your mail messages you
can see the body you can see the
individual sections how the mind format
breaks down you can see the raw message
content for the whole thing so if
something doesn't look right this is a
great tool for diving in and figuring
out how that works so you've got works
on my machine in a browser you've got
works on my machine with an SMTP relay
let's see if it actually works on the
internet
mail trap is a fantastic bit of kit that
I've used on dozens of projects over the
years mail trap again it pretends to be
a mail server so you send your mail via
mail trap and instead of sending it it
intercepts it gives you some of the same
features that Papercut does so you can
see different representations but then
it's got tools like this so that's your
HTML that's your HTML Source that's your
raw message body this is your spam
analysis this is all the reasons why
that email might get picked up as junk
now if you look at this one real closely
I got a 0.8 on there and I got a whole
string of zeros but the 0.8 is because
the domain name that I sent it from is
less than 28 days old
and this is the kind of thing they pick
up on if you're warming up a project for
a big client who's going to send a lot
of email you need to start sending email
early because it can take a couple of
months for their outgoing relay their
domain name and everything to be trusted
and established by Services all over the
internet I'm going to do the HTML check
on here now this is going to say look
this is the stuff that you ended up
using in that email and this is where
it's not going to work like you've got a
thing in there so Gmail's mobile Webmail
is flag two issues that won't render
properly on that all the way down to AOL
and iOS and the FastMail desktop Webmail
all these kind of platforms now let's
assume we have done our due diligence
we've tested all these platforms we've
designed the email the client signed it
off and we've tested it on Gmail iOS
Android Outlook Zoho proton FastMail
Yahoo Thunderbird Eudora Vivaldi mail
and Pine and then we get that WhatsApp
from the client go and the email doesn't
look right and you're like what
like send me a screenshot and they send
you this and you go
I absolutely believe that we all have
the right to consume digital media in a
format of our choice using our chosen
fonts color schemes devices layout
screen reader accessibility whatever I
also think that dark mode email is an
Eldritch Horror that should never have
been allowed to live
I wanted to find a friend of yours who's
a graphic designer I want you to ask
them to design you just ask them to
design you a book cover or something and
then mention in the brief oh yeah by the
way uh we don't know yet if it's going
to be on black paper or white paper is
that a problem because they're probably
gonna slap you because the first thing
you think about when you design things
like marketing collateral is what are we
going for here is this like dark with
light or is this light with dark giving
the client control over that on
something like email just opens you now
there are CSS rules and selectors that
are supposed to let us do multiple
versions of everything they don't
actually work terribly reliably they're
getting better but
the situation we have now is if you've
got transparent pngs in your email you
just need to come up with something that
works on both and often if it works on
both it doesn't look great on either of
them you end up having to put like
little outlines around your logo so
they're still visible and they don't
disappear into the background
and this is you know I find it immensely
frustrating as a developer whose job is
to maintain and support these kinds of
things but I also think it's incredibly
healthy and the reason why
so many of these things exist validating
email and is this email address valid
email is a moving Target
it's not fixed nobody controls it it
isn't like someone says email version 2
will be active as of today it is a
distributed Federated system where
different people are free to implement
parts of that protocol however works for
them they do what works for their
systems an email address is valid it
worked yesterday that doesn't mean it
still works today email that rendered
properly last week may not render
properly this week something that didn't
work last week someone might upgrade
that client it works suddenly and as
challenging and frustrating as this is
as a developer
I love it
because no one can mess with email
Zuckerberg and his cronies can't come
along and kick you off email the way
they can kick you off WhatsApp or kick
you off Instagram or Facebook or get you
banned from Twitter or you're not
allowed to use signal anymore I can set
up a server and you can set up a server
and we can talk to each other and we can
send each other email using Open
Standards and open protocols and it is
one of the last systems left which
allows us to do that without a
multinational corporation wanting to
harvest our data verify our accounts
make sure we are who we say we are use
algorithms to sell crap to us and
throttle the whole process if it decides
it doesn't like us now
that is where we are going to end the
version of this talk that is going on to
YouTube